près de 11 millions et demi d'entre vous
étaient devant leur petit écran hier
soir pour écouter les annonces de jean
castex
le premier ministre a présenté de
nouvelles annonces restrictives afin
d'endiguer l'épidémie de kobe 19 plus
d'attestation de sortie à partir du 15
décembre mais un couvre feu de 20h à 6h
du matin à l'exception du 24 pour le
réveillon de noël pas d'exception en
revanche pour le 31 décembre
la bonne nouvelle reste que les français
pourront voyager dans le pays et
déplacements entre régions sont de
nouveau permis alors qu'en pensent les
tourangeaux réponse avec lucas chopin et
paul boyer juste ne fait rare pas avec
ma femme ma fille et ma soeur
peut-être un beau-frère voilà ça va être
tout ça va être très très simple avec ma
famille chez moi en respectant bien sûr
ma direct du coup on serait on sera
assez restreint en nombre en petit
comité avec les filles et puis le petit
fils voilà pour le 24 au soir je pense
que je vois me retrouver un petit peu en
famille bien que donc avec le
confinement tout le monde ne puisse pas
venir je pense qu'on va quand même
essayer de garder un petit peu cet
esprit de noël
[Musique]
pour le nouvel an là c'est encore plus
simple parce que là on va être deux ou
trois particulier en temps normal je le
fais tu es pas déjà donc apprécier plus
pour les jeunes nous c'est un peu
compliqué mais bon pour moi ça changera
rien on a forcément envie de se
retrouver avec avec nos amis
malheureusement c'est vrai qu'avec avec
ça je pense que ça va se faire en
famille également
[Musique]
le reste est à tour enfin en touraine
disons parce que j'habite à côté tout
voir ma famille dans la même région que
moi donc ça va pas être nécessaire je
vais me déplacer pour aller voir mes
parents que ça fait deux mois que je
suis pas allé les voir et je pense que
c'est important
après on avait prévu des week-ends mais
tout a été annulé ou malheureusement
toute ma famille dit encore ce donc mois
jugé que le choix de pouvoir rester ici